hello everyone and welcome to the
semi-finals of the charity cup it's
magnus carlsen versus ding learn and
this is game three of their match so far
the match has been incredible if you
guys are following it live you know what
i'm talking about game one and two have
been really action-packed and magnus
even had a winning position in game one
but it was a really really a hard one to
pull off uh and in the end it ended in a
draw
but this is game three it's also pretty
crazy and it's uh incredibly uh
difficult to play such a game and it's
incredible how throughout the entire
game the position is just always equal
if you are a machine but these gentlemen
are not machines even though sometimes
they do play as as as machines uh
it is just not possible to play out um
that way until the end as there is the
time factor so let's check it out magnus
has the white pieces and he opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 by ding c4 e6 uh
we have knights to f3 and now d5 so the
queen's gambit decline is on the board
and magnus goes for his catalan opening
with g3 uh bishop to b4 with check we
have bishop to d2 blocking and now
bishop back to e7 so this is all very
standard nothing out of the ordinary
here bishop g2 with castles and queen to
c2 now developing the queen nicely c6
strengthening the center and now comes
bishop to f4 and this is a very very
tricky line uh it's another new move it
has been played before usually people
just castle here but magnus goes for
bishop to f4 and the bishop will be uh
well uh better placed here than on d2
and now we have knight b to d7 and only
now after bishop to f4 was played magnus
goes for h4 and it is now as of move 9
that we have a completely new game uh
magnus grabs more space on the king side
maybe he's interested in further
advancing the pawn maybe he's interested
in keeping the rook on the h file maybe
he's not castling king's side so dean
will have to find out ding plays b6 he's
ready to develop his light square bishop
go after the c for pawn knight to c3 and
now bishop to a6 uh so here as the c4
pawn is uh attacked we have c captures
on d5 we have a trade captures on d5 and
not magnus does castle king side
we have b5 by ding uh trying to
dislodge the knight from c3 via the b4
move uh and magnus stops pawn to b4 by
playing a3 we have rook to c8 and now
the knight cannot move the queen is on
c2 and rook f to c1 bishop to b7 now
preparing to further advance those pawns
a5 b4 of course is the threat and now
queen to b3 just moving the queen away
from the uh open c file and going after
the b5 pawn so a6 uh ding defends it and
now knight to a2 remaneuvering the
knight offering a trade of rooks along
the open c file so first rook the c4
ding says all right if you if you want
to trade you can capture and then i will
capture back with with the d pawn or
with the b pawn depending on when you
capture it for example if rook captures
we're going to play d captures on c for
attack the queen and okay it's not a
pass pawn but it's a it's an incredibly
impressive um queen side pawn chain so
instead after rook to c4 we have e3 now
magnus will play bishop to f1 or maybe
knights to d2 to dislodge the rook from
c4 force uh ding to capture uh with rook
captures on c1 uh h6 and now knight to
d2 so now the rook is challenged you
have to play something we do have a
trait on c1 captures captures uh sorry
captures and now knight
sorry queen to a8 uh freeing up the c8
square for the rook and then the other
rook pair will get traded off as well so
here magnus plays bishop to c7 and this
is quite a journey this bishop made from
from d2 to f4 to c7 the bishop is
actually going to a5 then to b4 and then
well you'll see so here rook the c8
putting the bishop on the only open file
on the board sorry the rook
and bishop to a5 now we have knights to
e8 and now comes queen back to d1 uh we
have knights to d6 and now finally rook
captures and c8 queen captures and
bishop to b4 so magnus for the moment
prevents this knight from coming to c4
as the bishop on e7 would hang but ding
has another knight he plays knight to b6
now this knight is coming to c4 as this
is a beautiful outpost for for the
knight now magnus could play b3 uh but
then he's also giving up the b3 square
for his own knight and um it's uh if you
don't have to play it then you will wait
with this move as as long as possible
once you push the pawn you can never
unpush it so here knight to c1 and
knight b to c4 so this is now a monster
knight and the magnus has to address
this somehow knight to d3 and now the c5
square is available to the carson's
pieces also the knight might be coming
to e5 all depending on what being plays
with a5 challenging the bishop and now
bishop to c5 with a4 uh ding is playing
with the with the black pieces here and
his position is just uh incredible uh
there is no advantage here for white
whatsoever and he uh can be very happy
with himself knight captures on c4 now
we have d captures on c4 and now knight
to b4
so carlson also placing his pieces very
nicely now the bishop trade is on the
table and of course dean goes for bishop
captures on g2 king captures and not
knight to f5 and this is
up until this point it's been a very
interesting but now it gets uh
incredibly interesting as magnus pushes
e4 he says all right this uh square is
too active for your knight please remove
it somewhere or where do you move it to
well you could move it somewhere but
it's even better to play with ding
played he played queen to b7 he pins the
pawn and says i will now be capturing
this pawn on e4 but magnus says that is
not happening and you might imagine
something like queen to f3 being played
or even queen to g4 being played or some
other moves like that but no magnus
plays king to f3 and we have reached the
position from the thumbnail so he
defends the e4 pawn with his king and
that is not just weird but also it's
really awesome to see so how will ding
uh
play this he pushes e5 he he wants to
weaken the bishop on c5 because of
course if captures then you're going to
lose the bishop on c5 and if you capture
on e7 then the problem is there's knight
to d4 with check and once you move the
king only then we capture here and again
it's just black who's better here this
knight is a monster uh you have a three
to two advantage on the queen side it's
if anyone is winning this it's
definitely black so magnus plays the
only move that doesn't uh give black any
serious advantage and that is knight to
d5 he is now
attacking the bishop twice and here
bishop captures on c5 the captures and
now knight to d4 with check king back to
g2 and now king to f8 the ding starts
bringing his king into the game and
magnus says all right this knight is
very uh impressively placed here on d4
let's uh undermine it with f4 now of
course black would very much like to
capture here but then he hangs the
knight so here queen to c6 going after
the c5 pawn and magnus plays queen to h5
he says all right you capture this pawn
i'm going to capture this pawn and that
will of course be great for white so
here dink plays f5 he now gives cross
and a taste of his own medicine if
magnus captures here then he just loses
the knight here
so if captures an e5 instead we have f
captures on e4 and now
carlson's position is incredibly
difficult to play and in fact if you
don't find it the only move on the board
you're just a lot worse and magnus of
course finds it uh but it's not an easy
move to spot he plays pawn to e6 now
he's threatening checkmate on f7 uh but
also it's uh just uh that he's giving up
upon uh so here dean captures it and now
comes across his idea knights to f4
attacks the queen you can see that the
knight can also reach the g6 square but
there is also a lot more in the position
because dink just plays queen to f5 he
just won a pawn he offers a queen trade
but magnus now has this beautiful queen
to d1 with tempo attacking the knight
here that is currently undefended and
you could very easily go wrong because
ding is uh at around the 15 second mark
and if you play something like queen to
d7 let's say he defends the knight
magnus would just capture it and that's
it queen captures knight to e6 czech
force the king and the queen king will
move and we're gonna pick up the queen
we're up a full knight we are of course
completely winning here so dink find uh
finds the absolute strongest idea he
plays g5 and now of course the the the
idea doesn't work because your knight is
hanging as well uh and magnus plays h
captures with h captures and queen
captures on d4 we have g captures on f4
and now magnus starts pushing his pass
pawn
if you try to break up a black spawn
structure it doesn't really do all that
much black will always have this queen
to g for checking here queen captures
here and this is basically a draw
because uh well black can always just uh
you know continue checking you and
there's not all that much you can do
about that so magnus pushes c6 and now
we have f captures on g3 again something
like something like f3 check looks uh
impressive as you keep your pawns
connected but after king f2 you have no
more checks it's just the white was not
much better so uh very careful
uh
moves
have to be played so here we have f
captures on g3 and now you already feel
that ding
well
if he has queen to f3 check there's just
no way possible to to lose this position
uh but magnus just continues pushing c7
and when you're down so much on time
like ding is in this game and you see
the spawn advancing all the way to c7 it
just seems like a like a very very uh
scary thing and also the problem is if
you play queen to f3 check now
then king to g1 and all of a sudden how
do you continue this with black there's
no dis check the queen covers this the
queen covers the f2 square there's no
queen to d1 the white queen also covers
that so uh wha what can you play there's
simply nothing you can do and white is
threatening promotion so white will be
winning this game so ding of course uh
being as impressive as he is finds the
only move that doesn't lose king to f7
uh and now okay the queen still covers
the the queening square so you don't
have to worry about that but now magnus
plays queen to a7 now he's threatening
to queen with a discovery so how do you
play this uh there are actually a lot of
possible ways to
not lose this game for a forwarding uh
queen to f3 now being one of them you
could also play king to e8 you could
play king to f6 uh one move you cannot
play is the move that ding played the
ding played king to g6 and this is not a
problem so you might think okay what's
the difference king g6 king f6 there is
a huge difference but feel free to pause
the video and try to find the only
winning idea for magnus while i give you
a couple of seconds
which is basically how much ding had
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the only
winning idea in the game and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is queen to e3 that's the only move
that wins because now as the king is on
g6 we are threatening queen captures
uh on g3 with check also we are
preventing ideas like queen f2 queen to
f3 all of those ideas are simply
insufficient as our pawn is one square
away from queening so here ding has to
go back king to f7 was played but now
magnus just plays queen captures and g3
uh and what do you play now we have
queen to e6 now magnus just plays queen
to h3 attacks the queen and if the queen
moves then the queening square is
covered we have queen to g6 with check
king to h1 and here ding picked up the
queen he wiggled it around a little bit
like this and then he just dropped it to
f6 because he realized that there is
nothing more to be done here and he was
in this position on move 50 that the
english resigned the game uh as there is
nothing more to be done here
uh
you will queen the pawn and that's it
but just uh uh
quickly uh go back a few moves uh here
where ding played this king the g6 move
had he played king to f6 then it's a
different idea then you don't have queen
to e3 as this is not being threatened
with check and we can just continue our
journey towards the c pawn queen
captures on g3 king d7 and now you are
no longer winning this game as white as
you don't have to worry about this pawn
if anything it might be black will be
winning this game black is up a pawn but
still it should be a draw with perfect
play
but then in the end after this king to
h1 move there is simply no way of
stopping the queening uh to give you an
example you might play something like e3
try and uh deliver some uh crazy
checking ideas maybe try to find some
perpetual uh but after something like
queen the c8 check white will have to
suffer a few checks of course king g2
queen captures here with check king of
three you can even allow this check king
to e4 now queen to c2 let's say with
check you're gonna go up the board queen
d3 check king to c5 and now after queen
captures an a3 check you will play king
to c6 and there are no more checks so
whatever you play here you are getting
checkmated in two moves uh let's say you
try this to try and you know uh sneak
one in
but it will not work as just queen to e6
checking g7 and now queen to g8 will be
checkmate so this is what would happen
and of course the dean knows this so
after he wiggled the queen around a
little bit dropped it to f6 like i said
on move50 he resigned the game so
incredible stuff an incredibly intense
game i really thought that it would end
in a draw but uh ding spent a lot of
time defending and he he played like
maybe 15 or maybe even more of his last
moves uh playing only an increment with
10 seconds on the clock and then it was
easy to make a mistake like this here
where you can play king to f6 king the
uh g6 was played and the disc was just
enough because it allowed magnus
everything not only is the king so far
away from the actual defense of the c7
pawn and not only do you allow the white
queen to pick up the g3 pawn with check
and also from e3 to to guard all of the
squares where the black wing can deliver
checks it was just
it was just the only move that allowed
magnus to win and the dink played it in
time trouble so yeah that's the game i
hope you guys enjoyed it never allow
yourself to go in time trouble unless
you really have to but that's you know
even if you are as strong as ding that
time trouble affects everyone
so yeah i would like to thank jay length
and consulting father fararoni drippers
cyberclub nft blueberry friends twitter
and rob rob for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
semi-finals until we reach the finals so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day